coming to you in five four three two
hello and welcome h3 warriors today we
go to war that's my new thing
get your Forks pitchforks and Spears and
torches especially because it is a
drama-filled juicy day everybody rejoice
and celebrate because not only is it
Friday today the Lord's Day well the
lower state would be on Sunday but I
think the Lord also likes Friday
am I wrong Gila the Lord's Day is
actually Saturday in Israel so in
America the Lord's Day is Sunday which
is which is the true Lord's Day because
the Lord can't have two different days
so you guys need to get on the same page
there I'm saying my Lord's Day if I'm
the Lord it's Friday because TGIF baby
thank God it's Friday
thank you Lord quit you know who said
that originally Jesus Jesus Jesus what
was I talking about
juice Eve drama-filled aspect very
special episode of the H Street podcast
brought to you thank you too for hymns
and ring for bringing us this juicy
drama-filled episode they're just our
sponsors they're coincidental they don't
they didn't bring us the drama like for
hymns lake today like four hands gave
Jared the boner pills to just surge him
over the top Pro Jared I'm sure you guys
heard this is a phenomenal I've got a
lot to get to first of all we made a new
video Instagram versus reality and then
this whole drama blew up from that which
I totally did not expect my goodness
this girl Trisha pay Yatta Yatta
anyone help me out back there with the
pronunciation it's Paytas oh my it was
even close I just saw some peas and some
raisins amazed not a scientist Trisha
Paytas so we've got that to talk about
she made a video crying on her kitchen
floor which surprised me just surprised
me at all but we'll talk about that in
response to my video then pro jared is
this phenom from whole fro jared is this
phenomenal I've never seen the likes of
which a drama has
has totally destroyed and burned a man
alive he was consumed by it so I'll drag
him fire yeah
it's frightening it's quite frankly how
quickly this man's whole life as you see
on the TV his subs even now are just
dipping into the abyss
he started over he had won let me show
you I'm getting ahead of myself but I
want to show you for context if I just
go pro Jarrod socialblade I don't know
even in all my time on YouTube with
Logan Paul with what are the other big
ones like I mean with leafy and Logan
Paul those are the kind of the two
biggest backlashes I can think of him in
modern YouTube history I have never seen
a single lost day like this a hundred
and three thousand lost and one day I
wonder if that's a record I think it is
I I don't know at what's remarkable is
that like he has a million subscribers
that's that's 10% of his entire fan base
look vanishing like a Thanos snap like
to go from 50 to minus a hundred
thousand yeah just the difference yeah I
mean 10% the thing is like a million is
is kind of small by comparison to like
Logan palm leaf he's yeah so they didn't
have anywhere near that loss so the per
capita loss of actually losing 10% is so
staggering and it's still going on
obviously right now
I've never seen anything like it and we
may never see anything of the likes of
which again and there's just been some
absolutely phenomenal
memes the story is incredible the face
is outrageous that everything about this
is like a perfect storm
it's that category 5 hurricane that just
is that once-in-a-lifetime experience it
just puts a whole city under water
you know what I mean it's just I never
see anything like it so we're gonna dive
into that I've seen his [ __ ] too as well
today I mean and yesterday I made you I
know I've seen the uncensored one yeah
I've seen it all I've been there I've
done that I've seen it all so not not
because I wanted to actually well I
guess I won't say but somebody sent it
to me like on because I was talking with
somebody at great length about the whole
projared thing and and I told I'll keep
sending me the memes because they're
hilarious
and then so I kind of did ask for it but
then it just his dick like unfiltered
dick showed up and I was like we're in
boys yeah watch it fault dip I mean we
may witness the moment here where he
goes below 900,000 now imagine like
imagine so it's maybe I should just talk
about this I guess that's where hardian
is I'm gonna talk about the whole Trisha
thing after this because I'm already in
it I'm loving it alright so Jerry now so
oh my god I guess I should explain what
happened I just can't get out of the
mindset of like so he announced on
Twitter that him and his wife were
getting a divorce and he knew that some
drama was going to ensue because their
divorce was not exactly amicable and he
knew that now obviously he wouldn't
anticipate the what would unfold when
his now ex-wife accused him of cheating
behind her back with her colleague for
many years who was also formally married
to one of his colleagues and friends
they're all part of the same group of
friends yeah it's like it's incredible
do you there's this phenomena my god he
gained a subscriber somebody just what
found progeria is totally oblivious to
anything going on that I like this
project there's one subscriber what was
that you ever notice this phenomenon
like in a group of friends it's like
everybody just ends up like having sex
with each other because there's like no
other options like if you have like
let's say this happened in college but I
think with every clique let's say
there's like 10 people five dudes five
girls you know that
everyone's gonna [ __ ] each other like
eventually it just happens like where
everyone's like man I'm dating her out
and then dude I get it it's cool and
then it's like you everyone ends up
having sex and but so this is one of
those cases I think except that we're
married and adults and we're not in
college so I don't know how good of
analogy is just a phenomenon I noticed
as a psychologist sociologist yes in my
studies uh he just gained another
subscriber I find that more fascinating
at this point then anyway I loved his
analysis on Megaman 93 we were just
watching Pro charrids let's play I got
to pull this up I'm sorry guys I know
I'm me entering but this is just I got
to enjoy this because this doesn't come
around every every day
Pro Jared let's play was it called damn
Pro Jerry please don't you find his name
kind of funny like even if you actually
think about what it is
it's Pro and then Jared like he's a pro
gamer Pro Ethan like imagine that's mine
that's yeah like back in the day you say
like I'm Pro he's Pro Jared cuz he's so
dope but anyway he posted a let's play
one day ago and I was just watching him
yesterday before his whole world can
crash me down it's like last images this
is a subreddit called last images of
like people with loved ones before they
passed on he just doesn't know he just
doesn't know he is just playing Megan
you know who cares just take it in for a
moment acoustic yeah that was this penis
coming out boy other snow okay well can
I go to anyway
god I really taken a long time get to
the point but imagine he walks away from
his computer like I've been through the
meat grinder I've been through drama and
usually what I'll do is I'll be like man
I'm really upset this is too much for me
to handle I'm just gonna walk away from
social media for a couple days and let
this blow over so imagine when he walks
away he's got a million thirty thousand
subscribers and he comes back suddenly
he just comes back he's a tall check my
social blade see what's the damage you
know a couple thousand you know he comes
back and he sees one hundred thousand
loss in a day this was trending on
Twitter for it's like at the top people
are fascinated by it almost like this
morning yes then like nobody talks about
Jared but somehow everybody's obsessed
with the scandal it's at Twitter
trending the top of the news there's
okay let me just tell you what happened
for Christ's sake
okay the there's just so many layers to
the story you know so here's the three
at the center of this love triangle so
this is Jared in the middle this is like
Game of Thrones if I'll let you finish
the sentence Jared
his ex-wife on the left yeah on the left
and on the right is the his true love
it's a mystery
the mistress thank you you long very
well sir correct yes yes I think so
absolutely
and now Jared now what fascinates me too
is like this is the guy at the center of
this by the way this is the picture he
chooses to put on all this videos well
I've seen pictures of him that aren't
this bad but I find it fascinating that
this of all of them is the one he
chooses to present to the world I'm not
gonna yeah I don't know what to say
really without being too solid yeah I'll
mail right there yeah
that guy takes probably 20 alpha males
brains a day so anyway so why is this so
epic why do so many people care about
this why is this been trending for days
nobody's experienced anything like this
before so here's my theory on why first
of all this is blowing up so big first
of all he's goofy looking that makes it
all the better because you see a picture
of the sky near like a whole man he's
been sending nudes to underage girls
cheating us wife I'm in for his dick
there's dick pics involved there's
pictures of his dick all around the
internet instantly juicy I'm involved
also when the wife twitted about saying
that he cheated on her you know for a
few months glad you showed that he
blocked her oh yeah fantastic love it
yeah no that's amateur a couple see I
don't know how to appropriately tell the
story so if we're everywhere just bear
with me it's gonna be everywhere it's
tough but this this is a picture that's
on the internet that's it as well so I'm
in you know anything like it doesn't get
better infidelity underage sexting and
then it the story's been unfolding live
so it's just it's absolutely phenomenal
so let me open this summary and I'm
gonna tell you guys exactly what
happened now
so Pro Jared first of all announced that
him and his wife were going to file for
a divorce this is the very first thing
that happened he says a statement very
dramatic very dramatic he says wife ID
and I filed for C I don't know anything
about Jared or his wife or really
anything about any of these people but
I'm so in I know I've never watched his
videos but I do know some what the girl
did he cheated with who she was married
to and I knew that they were all part of
the same group which is why it's so it's
like so PAGASA
yeah oh
basically this is Game of Thrones if you
remove like all the graphics and the
fighting and uh I'm gonna read the
statement my wife Heidi and I have filed
for divorce I know this may come as a
surprise and upsetting for many of you
but know that we do this so that we may
both seek happiness for ourselves during
this time you may see see a lot of
rumors speculation and gossip going
around I ask that you make your own
observation and come to your own
conclusion I guess everybody did do that
I love how we preamps it with like he's
like my life because I move Lord only
knows I will add to this decision was
reached after extensive individual
therapy on my part and couples therapy
together what that said this is all I'll
let plan on stating publicly regarding
this matter Heidi's privacy mental
well-being and discretion has always
been a will remain my eyes priority
through all of this is my hope that we
can both exit this marriage with style
and grace that sentence stuck out to me
style grace I understand what style he's
like I'm coming out of this mare maybe I
don't know about this style wait to see
the pictures you've been sending
underage girls you want to talk about
style I hope that we can exit this
marriage with style anyone want to see
my dick and grace I plan to continue to
do everything I can on my part to make
this happen
thank you for understanding patience
kindness and respect for our privacy and
his dick pictures out well actually well
so the one that opened the lid on this
one was actually his what ex-wife Heidi
who's divorcing yeah exactly so this is
only the beginning of the juice of of
what is and so what follows from that
statement is that his now ex-wife Heidi
so actually no so so now this is the
girl who left she was left the top
comment on his explanation about getting
divorce she said I'm so sorry you're
going through this I'm here for you if
you need me this is from Holly Conrad
who who is a unknown player until his
ex-wife
not unknown though cuz their followers
no I mean they didn't know that that's
the girl he's cheating with mm-hmm
nobody knew that at the time can you put
the balls of her that you're getting
you're the cause for like the divorce
and then you're leaving comments like
that so yes now here we go here's the
tweet from from the wife she says this
is her response I've recently learned
that my husband Pro Jared has been
[ __ ] Holly Conrad that's the girl who
said she's feel so bad for him behind my
back for months I have no idea what
announcement he just made because he
blocked me bro how epic is that what
happened to styling great yeah I hope
that you can respect my my privacy
well I've getting this marriage of style
and grace Bichir blocked my ex-wife so
fantastic you could just mute her you
know like god damn idiot what's his last
name
hmm neighbor neighbor Navin Bauer been
nob and his neighbor alright nahban
Babur so we got Jared number Bopper over
here knob in his neighbor as Dan put it
so the two girls were friends
yes and Holly is not divorced but she
was married to Ross who's a mutual
friend who's a mutual friend of him too
yes
I just can't get over at home the
dynamic yeah yeah also I can't get over
the fact that Jared is so seductive that
he's like breaking up marriages I mean
that should really give hope to all you
frickin like in cells out there like
Jared Jared a single handedly smashed
the in cell movement you know what I'm
saying like how dare you think that
you're unfuckable when Jared is out
there breaking up marriages mm-hm
stop hitting yourself loser it's you
Jared smashing like crazy oh you know
what I'm saying like you cannot I'm
sorry
but if Gollum can [ __ ] and so can you
and I'm I mean like imagine golems on
tinder getting [ __ ] did you know
anyway so as more information is learned
the so it is clear that Heidi is telling
the truth people started turning on her
but it turns out she's been telling the
truth and there's been going on for
months since October then it comes out
that projared has been soliciting
not-safe-for-work pictures from fans and
has sent a few of his own were still
these were sent while he was married
Heidi was however fully aware that he
was sexting with fans for a few years
which to me is a huge area more huge
question mark that's that's strange but
but now since this dramas spread his
sexting images that were being sent out
all these girls and are now sharing them
on social media like wildfire obviously
I'm not gonna show you any any dick pics
or lewd photos but they're out there and
trust me they are lewd I don't think ya
had a final piece of garbage it turns
out that many of the fans he was
attempting to solicit photos from and he
sent two were underage mm-hmm and so I
don't know how corroborated that is but
I guess it's an ongoing investigation
but I've seen some credible evidence and
I thought wouldn't surprise me at this
point I mean the guy sending his dick to
everyone who with eyes I mean apparently
they're saying that he even had like a
nudes tumblr or I don't even know why
yeah he had several not-safe-for-work
tumblers that he used to reach out to
fans how does that happen well the guys
obviously you know he has some kind of
sex the thing for me is that I know the
kind of audience that watches videos
like his and they gotta be like at least
90% on their age I mean though I think
you're right
yeah the age demographic that watches
this videos yeah I think you're right
the girls who have come out and said
that they were 16 at the time so mm-hmm
yeah so let's so that's that's the story
this is when she started getting brutal
his ex-wife was just going ham on him
and this here let's see here
honestly Holly
you look very ashamed and insecure and
all the nudes you sent my husband I
think it would help your chronic
self-esteem issues if you start a
[ __ ] min that weren't already married
damn times like this where I look it's
just it's so nice to just sit back and
be like but it's [ __ ] brutal this
shot in freund him how do I sit all
right writing something like that yeah
dan let tell me when we're out of break
time because I'm not I'm it's not I got
ten more minutes okay it's just
remarkable because I've been through
YouTube drama it's the worst it's just
the worst and this is so beyond anything
that any of us have ever imagined
possible then I'm just like Pro Jared
more like sad chairs life is over
more like Jared from Subway more like
Pro Jared from Subway
anyone is the name jared like done no
yeah Jared I cancelled I mean [ __ ] let's
pray face it Jared wasn't that wasn't
that strong of a name to begin with
apologies everyone I'm sorry
yeah I should've thought of that but I'm
saying you know I guess when your
parents I don't think there's many
Jared's coming out these days is what I
would adventure to guess Zach but I
think yeah if you named her kid Jared
like in the past two three years that's
a mistake
I agree yeah and no offense to your
brother I think he's probably awesome
just keep an eye on him to make sure
he's not talking to any underage girls
or anything cuz you got it there's
baggage with that name yeah keep an eye
on him
here I've got a meme his his subreddit
by the way has been converted into a
jontron subreddit which is specifically
funny because during John trans drama
he was extremely vicious kicked him out
of normal boots and was like one of the
biggest haters of jontron guy
specifically was yeah oh so he has to be
relishing this yeah so so they changed
projared so I read it into a jontron
themed subreddit well here let me show
you the subreddit and it's just turned
into such a dumpster fire his own
subreddit that it's a site it really is
a sight to behold
[ __ ] projared mega thread enjoying the
new sub icon here's jontron I opened
this up the other night to look at it
and I was like wait I was like ah
thought it was i'm projared not jontron
it's fantastic top post [ __ ] when you
unsubscribe from projared after watching
him for more than seven years but if you
go sort by top of all i mean it's all
like here's the top scumbag above this
image so it's the first thing she was up
when google shows scumbag it's so brutal
like that was on the front page of my
home page wait I gotta check if they
were successful with that I mean Google
Images right now no no it takes time it
takes time it's gonna take more time I
guess yeah yeah he's in the clear and
then like the mods betrayed him
apparently he was a mod on the subreddit
and everyone's like man he's just gonna
be erasing everything and blocking
comments
so apparently unread it there's a
hierarchy there's a tier so on
subreddits there's like the master mod
who established the subreddit and then
everyone else has like Kanban the person
below them so the guy who actually
started the subreddit banned Jared he
kicked him out so this is an reference
to that the Internet his wife Jared
projared mods sipping wine also start
beating the [ __ ] out of him yeah I don't
know so he was been banned from his own
subreddit and which was turned into a
jontron Dame subreddit so back to the
sub loss and I'll go over some memes
with you if I if I may
these have been prominently featured
yeah I'm a gamer gee cheat on my wife G
AME and there's no R yeah
but look at a little that face I think
that's really I think what made this so
delish I mean so incredible for
everybody people are doing to know him R
is that face and somehow just completely
making fun of his looks and like and
everyone is on board yeah on any other
day people are like dude you really
shouldn't be yeah you shouldn't be
relishing in the fact that his life is
ruined and you know these are people
that we're dealing with whatever no soda
every once in a while that's out the
window everybody in the world is like
[ __ ] this guy in particular yeah yeah
Momo challenge uncanny I'm not gonna lie
and I mean that is phenomenal bro if
you're an insult listening to this this
guy [ __ ] like crazy
both of these women too are like pretty
attractive it's like there you go there
you have it beautiful one going on I
mean you guys have seen the dick pics so
I don't know it's fine I mean it's not a
spectacular day it's a normal deck you
know oh what are your comments on it go
ahead I'm curious the pictures of him
well yeah where he's trying to be sexy
yes I guess I we were debating if we
should show those because we're like
well cuz they're not like I don't really
want to Jenna be like promoting leaking
yes that's their out there
y'all want to see it but they're all
like him being like as if he was you
know super sexy like him with like his
shirt in his mouth literally he took a
photo like this there's one of him in
the back like it's you know the guy
the guy is definitely working with what
he's got and if you're and so out there
they can't smash there's no excuse for
you so we're not use the word in cell no
they call themselves that no they called
they are the ones that to coin that term
it means a means invulnerable entirely
celibate in bolter yeah okay it means
they're virgins because they're I I
would assume just to socially inept but
they blame women they have terms they
call chad's and and what was it what's
the other one got like the opposite yeah
like the [ __ ] I think it's just yeah I
think it's cook no no this Chad and
another one Chad verse come on help me
out here isn't it just virgin Chad
versus version all right I'm going to
the internet to find this you got you
guys do the resist Chad versus virgin
and Chad versus in Chad Chad wait Chad
verse Brad is that right Brett no that's
not Chad were spread Chad uh and so
verse all right you guys gotta help me
out here I got a shield around but any
I'm googling it it's a Chad vs. virgin
or Chad versus instantly I know there
was a name for the insult but they
called it dudes who apparently are
handsome that women are have an unfair
advantage over them they call them
Chad's work I guess they think every man
is a bro and a douche and is a jerk okay
Jared is not a Chad Chad with Jay he's a
Jed all right let's get back to the
names so the biggest YouTube drama 2019
is really over dude that looks like this
huh
[Laughter]
you wouldn't feel comfortable it's so me
mobile but I think the fact that he's
pretty he's just so strangely confident
at the same time probably one of the
goofiest looking to is of all time
like I remember just casually looking at
his channel once and seeing because if
you go to his channel he puts his fat
face and all of his got you came to find
his YouTube channel with all the
gentleman yuki puts this face in all of
his thumbnails oh can you imagine if it
was any more famous what do we do right
so that's what happens we dark alley
that's right that's a great point you
know here we have a sex dungeon an
occult absolutely you're absolutely
right and the girls would have to call
him dad daddy anyway thought I'd seen
this somewhere before
yeah Jared out here looking like Jack
Jeebs from it though there was lots of
mini blossom [ __ ] Jack Jeebs from men in
black after he gets his head blown off
guys Jared cheat on his wife they're
getting divorce and [ __ ] and he's a
total piece of [ __ ] you mean to tell me
a [ __ ] looked like this I don't
get this one he doesn't look like that
dog not a good one bad one hi Jared oh
this was a comment this was an actual
comment on his announcement that they
were getting divorced Jared so sorry to
hear I hope you're both okay and I wish
you well then he comments I'm briefly
afterwards wait I just read what
happened I take it back
projared makes a tweet after blocking
Heidi on Twitter Heidi I'm not the end
this whole man's career here yeah I
showed you that one I found some this so
this this to me I couldn't stop laughing
keep the fire going it's called and it's
a picture of The Fresh Prince of bel-air
in the back of a taxicab like looking up
at the big city with a camera in his
hand he says me on this subreddit having
never watched one of Jarrod's videos I
was just cracking up dying because I
think 90% of the people must feel like
don't even know who he is
yeah they just love in the drum like
crazy
instead of Twitter calling projared an
alleged adulterer or alleged pedophile
they're calling him an alleged youtuber
and honestly that's so freakin
hysterical trending for you and it's
true it says alleged youtuber cheating
scandal unfolds in the public eye and
then here people who don't know Jared as
people who know who Jared is hating Pro
Jared and Holly cheating on their
significant other was someone less
attractive than their significant other
and of course the all-time best one
Jared I don't feel so good and it's his
1 million subscriber play button award
vanishing as if he was vaporized in
Afghanistan yeah by the way to go back
to the previous one yeah um yeah Holly
was with Ross as soon as Ross was a
handsome guy better catch yeah I mean
obviously I don't we I don't know we
kind of know I met him Holly we meant I
met him once I don't know that I can't
say I know the guy but he's a handsome
guy yeah I mean doesn't look like Momo
no he seems like a gem like a great nice
dude you know I don't know I don't know
if holly was look I don't know you know
funny
as far as Attraction looks I mean that's
correct I I followed up with some of my
own favorites that I was looking at last
night let's see he's about to go below
900,000 so that's special that we can
share this moment together let's see
what we have
so I wonder if Ross and Holly got
divorced because he also found out
because I actually am NOT I don't know I
think I think they had been separated a
while now cuz I I saw him on Twitter
being like guys I'm not involved I've
moved on
I don't I don't wanna hear about so yeah
so let's respect that and this was a
meme blocked my own life it's like a Toy
Story meme it's so funny it's just so
goofy I love that blocking her move that
was a huge mistake on his yeah that just
mute her man like that kind of said the
whole thing on fire absolutely I don't
know that it would have got the same
traction had he not blocked his way yeah
cuz that made her tweeting like
explosive when she's like not only did
it cheat on me with my friend he also
blocked me you know good blocking on
Twitter's a rookie mistake
don't ever block because it just gives
that person the satisfaction you mute it
saves the same thing and they don't know
that they're muted blocking is the
biggest rookie mistake of all time oh
it's break time I was it break time let
me read this last one here before we go
and break congrats disk [ __ ] killed
me Congrats a nine hundred thousand
subscribers been here since 1 million
[Laughter]
all that for son-of-a-gun
I started calling him oh oh my god he
just took a huge a big jump
congratulations on on nine hundred
thousand been here since 1 million
wonder if he'll get another hundred
thousand loss on day 2 of this whole
scandal mmm that would be incredible I
doubt it he'll probably get 50 though I
would someone had a great thought they
said I wonder does he need to send back
his play button now see - can I come
like possess it it just disappears
YouTube includes like uh uh technology
so that nating law he's already at minus
thirty thousand for the day there's a
lot of hours in the day left there's a
lot of fuel oh you know what I feel
I forgot that we are not live no we're
not affecting because I wasn't I was
wondering if we were affecting them
we're not live oh my god so when we post
this video it's gonna make me crazy
Wow so we're not being live isn't it
we're thinking about going live again
we're we we don't know we're pointing
the pros and cons it's kind of pain
about being live and definitely miss a
lot of stuff about it it's so actually
since we did the the new kind of chat
like I don't know the remembered yeah
Chad it's kind of nice to have that chat
you can see I love having the fan
interaction with the with the subscriber
only because it cuts yeah on all the
noise should we take a break down and
then come back I have a lot more Jared
means let's do it
so guys we shall be right back
congratulations Pro Jared and nine
hundred thousand subscribers
66% of men start to lose their hair by
age 35 and once you've noticed it's
thinning it's all ready to flip and
light is that hairline slowly starting
to move backwards do you see any bald
spots yet well the best way to prevent
hair loss is to do something about it
while you still can for Christ's sake
let's get a handle on those beautiful
locks before they fall out I ask you
this do you want two bolts about to pop
up on your hairline or your hairline to
recede or do you want to do something
about it first what do you guys turn to
weird solutions or do nothing when they
could turn to medicine and science of
the 21st century we got people in lab
coats doing science to keep your hair
and your gang ed thanks to science
baldness is now optional hems
before hems calm is a one-stop-shop for
hair loss skin care sexual wellness for
men hems is helping guys be the best
version of themselves with licensed
physicians and fda-approved products to
help treat hair loss this is not a snake
oil or a gas station counter supplement
my dudes this is prescriptions backed by
science I'm talking that lab coats and
and beakers and classic super thick
glasses for our listeners right now get
started with hims complete hair kit for
just five dollars today right now while
supplies last and subject to doctor's
approval see website for full details
and safety information this could cost
you hundreds if you went to a doctor or
a pharmacy somewhere else so go to four
hems dot-com / h3 that's fo r hims
dot-com slashed h3 that's four hams calm
slash h3 let's keep those beautiful
locks where they belong on your head and
that knot in the drain
do you see this device that is a ring
doorbell and ring security camera it is
the only device that I trust truly to
protect my home I have six of these
around my house and I have never felt
safer in my own home because this let me
explain this technology it's one of
those brilliant inventions that I praise
God and Jesus himself for Jesus okay
it connects to the internet boom it
gives you motion alarms if somebody
approaches your house boom
sets off your phone you can you can
adjust the sensitivity you could adjust
the motion sensitivity the range when
somebody rings the doorbell boom it goes
off on your phone let's say someone's at
your door they're ringing the doorbell
you can talk to them and see them and
they could talk to you through the
frickin doorbell it's a two-way comm
that also includes the spotlight I love
these spotlights you got motion
detectors the light blossom you can open
it on your camera and be like yo what's
up dude and they could talk back to you
you can also blast them with an alarm if
it's like if you're at home and it's
like someone's creeping on your house
you can not only yell at them through it
you can blast them with an alarm
it's so insane and here's the best part
like old alarm systems burglars could
just come in and unplug everything this
product automatically zips up the
footage to the internet immediately so
even if somehow they get in your phone
house where they disable the Internet
it's in the cloud you've already got it
you've already got the notification it's
the best product bar none
absolutely for securing your home or
apartment I love this product so much I
endorse it all the way I use it every
single day they've also got this
neighbor app where everyone in your
neighborhood close to proximity can
share and upload videos these guys are
brilliant they've created the social
network where you get a really good
strong sense for community and
neighborhood where if there's anything
shady going on they upload videos
sometimes there's funny stuff going on
there sometimes people get clowned
because they'll be like a delivery guy
went to the wrong address and they're
like watch out for this shady guy
everyone starts clowning on them because
it's obvious just wrong delivery it's
amazing it's like it's so entertaining
one way or the other and for my
listeners we've got a special offer for
a ring starter kit available right now
with the video doorbell and then
motion-activated floodlight cam I use
both those products I love them
immensely the right starter kit has
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home so go
to ring comm /h 3 that's ring comm / H 3
welcome back to the porch in episode I
just laughing at this meme this one
killed me to my morning routine wake up
he breakfast approaches breena's chief
Rajesh I had the same reaction you know
I've seen I haven't seen this meme for
fat in a long time so it kind of
surprised me when I first thought last
night I started cracking up think I was
delirious up so late come on this is
gold I'm not the only one 3,000 other
people love this I mean I did was just
blindsided by a picture of his penis -
so I had a very similar human experience
this one probably shouldn't crack as
much as it did but it [ __ ] killed me
Jared subreddit staring at a picture of
himself with the Red Cross over it
stupid [ __ ] Garfield means did I hope
Garfield means make a comeback all right
well I mean a breakout they never came
back I mean it's time for Garfield a
break now they think oh yeah so a lot of
people image apparently gave this game
Metal Gear Rising a 4 out of 10 have any
of you guys played that I haven't played
that one play most the middle game so
people were about that because they
thought it was better and they think
that was the the ripple wave the first
time the butterfly wing that caused this
whole thing
[Music]
no not that funny are you uh I don't get
those kind of memes oh man
we're good enough you kiddin okay you're
you get you were gonna get this one all
right
this is the best thing that's come out
of this so this guy D SP was this we've
talked about here on the podcast but you
may have forgotten he's a he's a twitch
streamer who after ending a show jerked
off but left his camera on and this is
the faith that he made as he you know
reached the climax lot of Austria and he
comes back and he goes uh he comes back
after jerk off and he's like alright
guys we're back oh the cameras on
cameras on this whole time huh rocking
back and forth like this so this guy he
goes pro tip for concentrators if you've
done something worse than this whether
it's public or private or not yet if it
whether it's let me start over I have
issue I have troubles pro tip for
content creators if you've done
something worse than this whether it's
public or not yet quit because I'm still
here and you won't be and good luck
living with that with the picture of him
or ketamine with his head back now I
guess projared also goofed on this guy
which is why he's going in like pro
Jarrett kind of pissed off a lot of
people I guess which is why everyone's
relishing and and and his demise and
this is yeah I mean this is incredible
so there you have it there's one more of
course just looked a long segment I've
ever done Brock Baker cut this out and
I'm okay with that from a clip I cheated
and I'm okay with a cheated and I'm okay
with that yes I cheated yeah I'm okay
with the theory of it that should be
should sound like that
so there you have it I mean really
there's nothing left to say
I do think like you said there's a good
message here for anyone who is not
confident with their looks right okay
keep talking I'm a pulp a picture of pro
Jarrod as you as you always look on the
bright side right the one message we can
take from this but actually know the
real message is that you really should
not ever send a dick pic to anyone okay
if you're like a personality with
following dude that is especially if you
are a public figure of any kind if you
send a dick pic there's like a hundred
percent chance that that one day will
come out but actually like in his case
it's almost like it sounds like he's got
a problem yeah sending it to fans like
obviously it's gonna get out he knew
yeah unsolicited it's almost like he put
it out there himself pretty much well I
think he has an urge that was too
powerful and overcame his rational brain
and I think that he must have feared
this moment that he knew he would
sometimes forget but also most of the
time he's still remembered in the back
of his mind that's this house of cards
or in this case house of dick pics was
gonna be coming crashing down around him
and just remember that this is the
picture he chosing Lee put on all of his
videos okay we've talked enough about
purge Eric yeah right anyone else have
anything to add dan and Zach just rip
he's got a big nose that's all you guys
have dad is a douche bag obviously I
mean I felt bad for him at first when
this whole thing came out but then as
more more details and especially the
underage girl thing it's like okay that
part no sympathy
so well the part that I read of this
story and again I don't know if this has
been corroborated but the part that
really got me is that he received nudes
from a 16 year old girl who explicitly
said don't share these with anyone
because she knew he had a sex blog and
then he reposted them to a sex blog
without her permission now have an
underage girl I was like wow that's like
a slam dunk that's like the sillies bag
Olympics gold medal seriously yeah well
cuz yeah I mean when when it first came
out it's like this this is personal [ __ ]
this is between these people and like
you know I saw other people saying it to
uh what's the wife's name Heidi it's
like you know this isn't really cool to
be like you know putting this guy on
blast this is between you know private
parties or whatever but just as more and
more came out it's just like now this
guy's this guy's pretty [ __ ] scum he
kind of deserves it so yeah there is a
red flag for me about her too because
she you oh yeah
that is the best wrinkle and she said I
knew about it for years that he was
sexting with fans huh yeah yeah
suspicious I get the feeling that
there's more to this story I get the
feeling that but I mean through that as
a man I don't I don't know anything all
I know is that Jared I seen chairs penis
I mean that's the only relevant so how
is it how is it it's fine I would it's a
fun it's a normal penis no like you were
gonna comment on it no I was just more
commenting on the those pictures right
not the penis I would give his penis
like doing like sexy pose talk about
that I have amnesia which I've seen
those but they were like the censored
version where somebody like drew you
know a [ __ ] joystick over his dad was
dick now how would you rate it out of 10
neela the penis itself yeah it's normal
five right yeah I would give it a 5 yeah
yeah give it a 5 inches probably
probably roughly yeah 5 out of 5 5 4 5
inches now what would you give Jared as
all total package
I don't want to be to me yeah you don't
mind y'all that should tell you about
this course so I'm surprised how the
hell is it that you like sleep in the
same bed as me cuz I'm such a monster
like I see myself as on projared level
of like not very far thank you but I
just I'm kind of a monster you just
gained some weight that's it there's a
there's a handsome dude under that
you're you're working you're working
with just compared to approach err
there's a handsome dude somewhere under
your fat thank you I saw those those
photo shops oh yeah I wanted to talk
about yeah okay thanks good damn boy
thank you Dad for getting me off the top
okay so now we're going to talk about
Instagram reality video first of all is
something that we made this video
there's a subreddit called Instagram
verse reality which I love and I
frequent where they take pictures of
social media celebrities and compare
them to candid photos to ship to show
you what a ridiculous difference there
is and some of them are just
breathtaking I mean it's kind of
mind-blowing that was my reaction at
first when you started showing me some
of those submissions on that separated
yeah and and their mega these are mega
celebs I'm talking about like the
Kardashians first of all there's some
that they just look horrid I mean the
Kardashians there's something weird that
happen with the Kardashians we're like
10 years ago everyone's like oh [ __ ] the
Kardashians they're a bunch of fake-ass
lame-o's they're destroying society but
now somehow like they've persisted and
people forgot that they're fake-ass
Lemos they're destroying society and we
started accepting them again like Kim
Kardashian is somehow like an ambassador
now and she's like a pop icon and her
sister is like this billionaire mogul
that people are saying she's self-made
and respecting
I mean they started this whole look that
now you see so many girls looking like
them right like I mean I see it a lot
the big ass everything they started the
pseudo ethnic do you know what I mean
like the pseudo ethnic white girl look
it's kind of yep yeah it's like what
wrong is makeup I don't know well no
they they they're like white girls to
try to look at yeah and and so that's
yeah I think that is that the movement
they started maybe that is to move it no
and a lot of just a lot of plastic
surgery yeah lip implants baked boilers
fake tits
obviously fake tits yeah I can't stand
fake tits on a personal note I've seen
Kim Kardashian's boobs and they just
they suck on my part that's just not my
personal preference I think that it
looks ridiculous like fake boobs like
that because they just look like I mean
it no longer looks like a sexual organ
to me it just looks like there's so much
shoved a bunch of crap and you're under
your skin and there's like stretch marks
and [ __ ] and it looks the thing is it
looks good and clothing for girls it's
just the whole subject is so complicated
because they feel so insecure when you
are kind of flat or whatever you know so
for some girls it can make them more
confident I get that I can total it's in
a really tough subject for women but I
think this whole new phenomenon of like
the whole body just looking like
complete just so far from reality like
the huge bot the tiny weight and what do
you call it waist
yeah and then huge boobs and like the
facial features like huge lips all of
sudden yeah super long hair extensions
just everything is fake oh the whole
look yeah and I first so I wasn't really
aware of that until recently a couple
years ago
we were I don't know when it was but
we're hanging out with a female friend
of ours in Israel mhm
and she kinda has like the same features
as a major skinny right come she's not
voluptuous not curvy but she's very
pretty
yeah she's a beautiful she's beautiful
just like you I mean you're both very
pretty girls grated cheese yeah yeah and
so she said to ela we were talking about
Instagram and she goes I hate Instagram
it makes me feel so insecure I feel
awful when I go in there all the time
and I was like what why would that why
I'm because I was like why I don't
understand it at all and then you were
like oh yeah I totally know what you
mean and I was just be I didn't even
think about that mm-hmm but I guess what
you guys mean is that there's this
beauty norm now where everyone has these
impossibly voluptuous bodies yeah and
features and for some reason especially
on Instagram it's like everyone it looks
like that yeah but so and so to hear her
say that which I thought she was like a
pretty and confident girl and so that
kind of blew me away because it seemed
to really affect her and so what you
realized through this Instagram versus
reality phenomenon is that these girls
are look just like you right or many
cases even worse but I'm not here to
judge
the thing is I'm only judging them
because they're the ones to put
themselves out there as these beauty
absolutely unrealistic picture of
themselves I don't know like
representation of something that
couldn't even exist unless you just go
modify your body a million times yeah
it's not even possible to achieve but
like there's one of Tanna where she's in
the ocean and her body looks like
perfect she's got like a perfect ABS
big round butt huge boobs but it looks
all natural and she looks like fun like
oh this girl's in phenomenal shape and
then you see it like a shot from an
insta story that somebody took and she's
like I said she looks like she went from
a mermaid to a manatee
and of course you know I'm trying to be
funny that's my primary objective here
so but but I consider her fair game
because she is the one that's
photoshopping herself putting it out
there I don't think that girls with
those bodies are manatees but I think
that think anyone took it that way it's
just look it's obviously a main joke
yeah it's a joke at her expense
obviously but not every girl who's
watching this I'm testing symbole we're
not the ones who's got a problem with
how she looks naturally exactly has the
problem and apparently everyone in the
word lately I don't know cuz all these
girls have like a hundred million
followers right right that's true even
Tana like any girl who's doing this is
just blowing up and everyone's loving it
it's weird who's consuming it because if
the girls hate it it makes them insecure
I guess they're their fans at the same
time they hate where you know is this
weird ambivalent thing so in my opinion
calling a Tana a manatee versus a
mermaid is first of all a funny joke and
second of all I've considered her fair
game for for photoshopping that so again
if you want to try to have a 300 like if
you just saw kind of looking naturally
without the other picture you would be
like oh look at this minute never of
course not never yeah exactly
thank you so everyone with a 300 IQ was
like you're being hypocritical and I was
like well that's true you do have a 300
IQ I didn't I possibly consider the fact
that it may be that it may be come off
that way so congratulations for the
Mensa members out there they pointed
that out I think I did see some comments
where people were saying those the the
the real pictures were like from her
Instagram story though so I guess to be
somewhat fair to her like she if she's
personally putting out the pictures of
herself where she doesn't look
photoshopped as well wait are you
talking what are you talking about I
don't even know if this is true I'm just
saying there were comments about Tricia
let's talk about Tana specifically yes
so I think it's maybe from like videos
right so like a make a video or like
in a video or a livestream I don't know
right where they can't they can't
Photoshop it yeah it makes sense but the
pictures that she personally uploads are
all looking and saying right first of
all there's a side-by-side comparison
you can see it's like one girls like
really out of shape normal totally
normal-looking body we're like and then
the other one is like supermodel nobody
is saying that she understood it we
don't I don't know if but I mean it
doesn't change the fact that that's the
photo that she puts out I don't know but
again I don't know if that's true or not
yeah I don't either is just these are
the same 300 IQ moments but regardless
so anyway that's the video and there's
some drama but then what really came of
this is is this girl Trisha bozer named
[ __ ] like haters hate haters I didn't
know who she was to be honest with you
but I guess she's a she's actually quite
a big youtuber she has like 5 million
followers or something and so we put her
in the thumbnail because her comparison
was just so epic to me and nothing
personal about her I don't know anything
about her obviously but I guess she has
a knack for dramatics somebody predicted
in the comments or on Twitter before she
responded he says you know she already
clicked bait a twenty-minute bit of her
crying calling it now so that was so
anyway so here's the response started
with a tweet she tweet there was like so
many there was like hundreds of tweets
I'm not even gonna
I'm not even gonna bother go through cuz
there's literally like 50 tweets but
this was my favorite one she says please
ela Klein do not raise your child to be
as ignorant as your husband I would
divorce him ASAP as he was causing so
much damage to young women it's actually
sickening I've never been more disgusted
that you stand by him is even more
disgusting so I guess is what's better
for our child is to be raised by a
divorced parent actually but again I
mean I acknowledge that the jokes were
made at her expense like her personally
but on the whole my mess everyone who
watched the video is gonna feel so much
better I saw so many comments were
saying I feel so much better
after watching it thank you and that was
my my secondary goal to make it comedy I
think just to focus on the those two
jokes that will obviously mean it is
just like you're missing the whole point
and also can we all lighten up like
actually if you want to talk about
raising children I'd rather raise a kid
that can laugh at themselves mm-hmm it's
like full I mean we don't need to be
like okay no one can make fun over
anyone anymore her profile at her
Twitter account is like blocked for
being nude she's like a pornographer
yeah I don't think you should I just
want to show her picture because I I saw
that tweet and I wasn't gonna say
anything but obviously when people
attack Ella it's mask off and I saw her
profile pic and I go who was this rude
person I don't recognize her from her
profile picture does anyone know her and
then she responded suicide suicide from
bowling it's [ __ ] real I pray to God
you never know anyone first hand to
answer life from that [ __ ] it's not a
joke it's [ __ ] real you sicko oh man
yeah she took it really she took it to
the max but I actually think that um I
think she enjoys it I think this is her
thing and she I actually do think I
don't I don't think she was actually
offended I think she is enjoying this
because she made a response video of her
cry and after as the guy predicted
crying on her kitchen floor of all
places and I have never seen her video
so when I first opened I was like god
damn like first my five a lot of
questions first is why are you on your
kitchen floor there's got to be a better
setting for this but I feel like she's
framed it up to be like as most just
like the saddest sight possible yeah oh
my kitchen cold floor tiles and front my
refrigerator yeah here let me show you
the beginning real fast
a tree tree is harmful girls is the
title and of course the downvote ratio
is brutal is actually a epic collab
because she linked my video and above
the fold and I guess she thought people
were going to come hate on me
this video needs to be deleted if he has
any sort of Defense sense he will and
she linked to my video but I saw I think
she she really got us a lot of new fans
because it's a good crossover I don't
think a lot of people of her fans would
ever watch our videos but I saw tons of
comments of people being like I came
here to hate on you after seeing her
video but this is videos awesome and
she's totally over the top or she
totally missed the point yeah a lot of
comments like that I don't think she
even watched the video because I'll show
you evidence of that but so I think this
was such an epic lab that she linked the
video like that fantastic
so here's the well you can't blame me
for that one I just made this video
[Laughter]
trying to contain and reel in my
emotions that's word a big platform and
like shaving these women like well I did
fast-forward to my party I don't really
watch other people Chloe and then right
after me talked about tannaz body like
her photo versus her reality I mean
literally on one of my photos that she
went from Beauty into a monster
I literally didn't say that back wait I
didn't say that
like come on I'm more insulted that I
think my jokes were were pretty good at
least quote what I said I think of her I
said she went from from Coachella to
open-casket funeral yeah no one really
got me or from Coachella to McDonald's
throwing down a McDonald's parking lot
area yes we see the WWF yes you and from
Coachella does it that was so no but
it's like but she's making it sound like
just lighten up it's and stupid jokes
like and such a well the yeah and the
truth is that I don't think anyone is
actually
upset accept her and I think she's doing
it because she enjoys it and I'd like
also to announce that our videos number
one ping suggested on our video yeah but
here this part was funny that Zack
spotted what doing the Lord's work here
on YouTube late well she just said he's
Catholic she's saying that she's saying
damn you just have to look we'll take
one look at my face and know that I'm
not good she was like oh he's a
hypocrite I guess cuz he's Catholic and
he's making fun of people
yeah well sorry lady Jews can say
whatever the hell we want yeah funny
stuff she's a character
she's the character that was an epic
Club I totally didn't anticipate it like
this came so out of left field
but I think I enjoyed it I think deep
down she enjoyed it as well I've got
lots of nice messages um my mom liked
the video and the messy mom we got mom's
like when you get break me break yeah so
there you have it that's about it oh and
then there was this fantastic follow up
but this kind of underlies the whole
that's not it
I can't show you guys that no I can't
believe I liked that instead of what I
wanted to I'll find it there was a joke
that was too cruel we cut it and I'm not
an Evo forbid me to repeat it but that's
it that's proof that I censor myself
there was a joke that was too mean I
thought it was very funny but we looked
over it when we were planning the vid
and we decided you know what this is to
me
yeah of course I totally got Ella's
approval on all those jokes going out I
mean sound cruel sound then we thought
about together well II lowest was yeah
she was more on the but I definitely got
you as approval before blessing that out
because as the you know by anyway this
was trying to show you guys this is
reality versus Instagram for you now
this is so it's so much like me it's so
much not like me like imagine you're
meeting a tinder date and the guy on the
right is who you're expecting and the
guy on the left is who shows up you know
it's so uncanny it's so much like me and
so much unlike me isn't it so bizarre
yeah man I can't get over it they like
fixed my jaw line I guess well I guess
he would be considered more like if
you're trying to just [ __ ] some dumb you
know some dumb dumbs on Instagram then
he would definitely fetch more you have
to admit that probably yeah nothing
wrong with him
I'd [ __ ] him it's a lot of people on the
subreddit say the Chad version of you
looks like Kobe person yeah this Kobe
and I [ __ ] that version of me it's
definitely more handsome but I don't
know what it is it is come on give me a
break
but it's like a different person it is I
almost feel like I you'd be cheating I'm
starting like to imagine this
personality guy it's Chad Klein but it
is it Sam it's the same nose the same
eyes same eyebrows the same lips or
maybe he made the lips fuller he fixed
the jawline that's the big one he he
removed no gray hair yeah no double neck
he smoothed out my skin oh and by the
way I was trying to show you guys in the
video itself like looking at my skin now
it looks like I have good skin but when
you look up close and I did in stories I
have so many blackheads my skin is so
disgusting I'm telling you up close we
are all monsters that was one of the
underlying things that I think the 300
IQ people missed as well
they were too busy calculating the
density of the black hole of the center
of our galaxy to appreciate the message
that we're all monsters
we all have blackheads we all have pores
and wrinkles and cellulite it's
disgusting
you know so that's that this guy
probably has a bigger dick though let's
be honest on the right Chad Klein yeah
could just be compensating you know no
check line is stacked put projared to
shame um god we've covered a lot of
ground was there anything else to talk
about with this one no that's it so hope
you guys enjoyed the new video I'm
working hard to make more content
I enjoyed that video I thought I was
very proud of that video because I had a
vision for what I want it to be
something that I've been trying to
envision for a while of this kind of
content that's like entertaining and
breezy and fun and light and a format
that really encapsulates it I was kind
of modeling it after the Mark Zuckerberg
video the rosette gets roasted and I
just I had a mission and I think that I
executed it really well and I and it was
a very nice it went very nicely the the
you know part of the reason why we took
a long break before was that the process
was so miserable and so this this
process was nice it was it was nice from
beginning to end when meaning just there
it's the whole part that you guys don't
see but like coming up with the idea and
then the recording part the editing part
the planning sometimes those parts can
be a nightmare when it doesn't go even
even as far as even the thumbnail and
the title couldn't even but mostly it's
the planning the recording and the
recording editing is always fine
so there you have it folks all right
shall we show shredder
oh yeah hit the interest with the
shredder came so sweet oh he's a little
out of frame that's all right you good
dad you know this is important I'm gonna
go reframe it um let's see I've got some
other stuff here let's just talk about
some stuff defeats the purpose of this I
want to talk about pointless Guinness
World Records there's two that I've come
across recently that have truly inspired
me first being this is one I just saw
fastest nose typer
you ask yourself it does everything need
to be a Guinness World Record you know
what I mean I didn't think of that yeah
no sniper what what is there really
competition it's like saying I might
want to get on this I have again I have
the Guinness World Record for person who
can blink the fastest you know it's like
okay you wanna get understand you want
you want to see me try does he have no
hands or something I mean to be honest
like he's fast but not that well he's
the Guinness world record but like you
said I mean how many people have tried
apparently the fastest is 40 point one
nine seconds what was the sentence go
back a little bit it said yeah I got you
it said gaff fair it's a Guinness World
Record have challenged me to type this
sentence using my nose in the fastest
time 40 points minute forty point 19
seconds yeah maybe but if he didn't have
hands still there's more effective ways
of typing like they're not [ __ ]
mutant freaks like people without hands
they're just picking everything with
their nose we have technology they have
give their voice we have voice detection
there's no reason for it
I was try and get it home it is really
hard but I guess you know with
everything practice so that one was
phenomenal dan do you want to try typing
something with your nose I mean it is
very difficult I might give it a shot
you're knocking [ __ ] like you can just
smash this guy you know here I'm gonna
try typing hi Dan ready here we go
hi damn pretty close yeah it's it's I
felt like my speed would mashed him I
think the problem is the accuracy yeah
yeah that's a good point
you can't see cuz your face is too close
you got to do it all but I feel yeah I
guess there's more to it I gotta give
him more credit yeah come on Dan don't
don't condescend his management's I mean
he's no walnut Smasher let's be let's be
real right know that that's the most
coveted of all the Guinness World
Records but like is any can anything be
a Guinness World Record do you know what
I'm saying what I think so some records
just don't need to be catalogued they've
sort of been brick that's smashing guy
oh there's no way to know what that
sounded somebody hit me with that again
bro that is like totally
indistinguishable hit me with that one
more time
all right that I've lost it you lost it
Wow just like that huh you can hear it
actually yeah you can hear it there's
that's pretty painful like when you know
what's happening and you imagine it in
your brain hit me hit me with it keep
going yeah okay so here is the largest
this has 50 million views holy God Wow
not even pro jurors penis has that many
views largest human mattress dominoes
okay
whose idea was this and how many
competitors are there like how many
people are competing in this category
I'm gonna mute this because the problem
is stupid maybe I'll just turn it down
but that exactly like why is this the
bank now why does it look like they're
at work yeah I think it's sponsored by
some mattress company they're gonna
resell those you know that they're all
covered in plastic and [ __ ] that's in
there their warehouse probably all these
overweight and wants fat in it do you
notice that oh it's a requirement
probably why to make sure you know they
only get fat people I think people I
think Americans are just fat there's so
many people in there don't you guys that
better she get to do like everybody took
time out of the day to do this we're
doing it no not everyone's fat that just
that row we what's the accomplishment so
Erin incorporated I'll hear their beer
being presented epic
oh they got silly putty so epic I won't
watch this again this was way too epic
to only watch ones how we can get claim
for this probably I'm gonna dispute that
all the way to the [ __ ] God just
don't block me largest human mattress
dominoes there's one row where
everyone's super fat like here it's
coming up like damn they're really
popping down something the guys are
eating [ __ ] kind of like on the curve
good comment so there's a pretty fine
they probably have medics on on oh my
god now I know why my mattress takes so
long to arrive
[Laughter]
dude this is so epic these people took
place in something really special
they'll remember this they'll totally
remember this by the way you can tell
here at this point some of these dudes
like that gap is too big and some of
them are intentionally falling they are
not being pushed whoa
like I'm serious like look at this guy
in particular he's falling back that I
do he barely got touched mm-hmm that's
the thing about the human aspect of the
domino the human aspect is fallible so
can we really call this a domino or do
you know what I'm saying Dan ya know I'm
I think it calls the whole thing into
question yeah I'm gonna have to contest
this with the official log can you file
a fish oh can you imagine if you
actually could get them struck from the
record I kept all this no so mean I'll
make like a video an h3 video yeah I was
I was jokingly talking [ __ ] about the
nose typer but at least that takes skill
this is just a bunch of people with
mattresses like what is this this isn't
any record this you just got a bunch of
mattresses together like what's what's
the accomplishment here the
accomplishment Dan really is how many
man-hours you can you wait like how much
progress productivity was lost you know
how sometimes like during natural
disasters the government will be like it
was estimate or like during the Super
Bowl or something to be like government
estimates there was like a trillion
dollars lost in productivity this is
like one of the biggest losses of
productivity ever to happen in Kansas or
ever this happened I know it's Kansas
because I didn't see one ethnic person
and everyone's overweight I mean I did
my talking [ __ ] about Kansas but should
I not have said that am I wrong
I I believe I saw one or two black
people in there you just messed over one
yeah there you go
but yeah oh there's a black guy oh
there's more of my talk I'm such an
[ __ ] don't listen to me don't listen
to me
cut up such a douche
largest human mattress thomas was watch
again that first guy is the first one
and that was so epic mMmmm watch this
this guy just pushes his ass so epic
that's the push that was heard around
the world this was such an epic moment
for them I wonder if the guy who was
pushing the first domino was felt bad
that he wasn't I attached to a domino
that's a good point kind of good out
here like he's the hero that stays
behind they keep the door closed you
know what I mean while the monsters try
to get in it's an epic sacrifice and
this broke [ __ ] so epic push that
Domino sick
did that second guy almost [ __ ] it up
that meant way too old to be eating [ __ ]
on a domino like that guy like like
honey broke his legs was it for him and
I wouldn't be surprised if someone
wasn't injured though because this is
not the model of health let's be honest
and those coroner's take it hard
those coroner's take it real hard right
watch the corner
they eat [ __ ] on the corner there's a
good corner shot here everyone's over
this but I'm not watch these corner
shots
this guy's bracing for impact [ __ ] a
speck those guys actually epic fall
right there dude that guy's huge all
right guys get it cuz you know how like
different mattresses have different
thickness mm-hmm one of the big ways got
them up their mattresses okay we wash
that enough times so there you have it
pointless Guinness records now next up
blushes bluffs through here guys were on
a roll
sanic sanic the Hedgehog trailer dumbest
[ __ ] I've ever seen in my life
who cares about Sonic Sonic fans are the
weirdest people in the world like who
even asked for this movie this look so
dumb seriously what do you think about
the Pikachu movie I think it looks dumb
I hate it
God last night Ian tell me how you like
it and don't say you liked it I'm
kidding you can say uh well I was in
that sweet spot for pokémon when I was a
kid so it hit me on the nostalgia level
pretty hard removing that it's just very
average very average movie everyone
trips out any time round Reynolds
anything I just saw the pictures like on
posters of Pikachu with a hat uh-huh I
just I don't know why I can't get it off
my head but I just felt like the
religious Pikachu what where you throw
that up I want to see religious Pikachu
he's not I bet it's just like why does
he have a hat on well let's find out
let's get to the center of this why does
he have
huh that's a good question why does he
have it a lot of times is it a Sherlock
Holmes Inge yeah he's a detective
wait okay I have no I so whatever
I thought you an explained that this
this is like a canon movie this takes
place in the the Pokemon world I I
thought this was gonna be like there in
New York or something you know and it's
just a detective movie with pick achoo
so this is canon this is like part of
the continuity of so riah making
pokemons I thought he just said Pikachu
well that's the thing he this is a
speaking woman I guess I don't know Oh
remember the the what was the cat that
talked in the anime mouth there's
precedent there's precedent for talking
Pokemon that's what I'm trying to say
well however bad I think that looks I
understand the nostalgia and it didn't I
mean if you know they made their best
effort Pikachu look true to form
but this sonic trailer is absolutely
unforgivable sonic cycle
I think Sonic just needs to go away yeah
it's not good no one gives a [ __ ] like
Sonic has been struggling from the very
inception of Sonic and the shadow of
Mario and everyone was always kind of
down with Sonic but at the same time
it's like I think Sonic just it's time
to just accept your fate are just
doesn't have that x-factor to be a movie
star he's got that extra x-chromosome as
what he's got it's an x-factor of some
sort sorry to everybody I offended with
that joke apologies in advance let's
watch this dumbass comp just yeah this
is watch this I mean the Sonic games are
fun but it's not like a claim for
showing this trailer what you get a
claim for showing this trailer well that
would be a [ __ ] joke Winnett I mean
well whatever I'll dispute it fair
enough
but like I can't get over when people
are making ads and I'm sharing that ad
like can you really own an ad it's meant
to be shared
anyway I'm caught whatever
he found an electric hair pube
[Music]
he's so humanoid Oh creepy it's just
yeah well why did he say gottagofast
isn't that a shitty like I think is this
tackling oh I thought that was just a
dumb meme or maybe it was just from a
meme I don't know
but gotta go fast like hello who says
that you trying to develop like a
relatable character and he's saying
gotta go fast look how it looks it's so
bad it's so bad it makes me angry that
Sonic is like a humanoid go fast is the
title of the theme song from the English
version of the Sonic the Hedgehog anime
so we've never actually said it stated
anywhere like I guess and meanwhile
they're playing gangster's paradise yeah
it's just no it's not used ironic I
guess it's meant to be ironic but
there's no like comedic Lee you would
expect gangster's paradise to go with
like nerds and a tie and a white shirt
like from office space they're playing
gangster music as these nerds in the
office so that there's this obvious
satirical use of the song yeah but
there's no obvious satirical use of
gangster's paradise here
it's just sonic saying gotta go fast
looking like a weird fanfic looks like a
tumblr version of like a sexual sonic
yeah that has a penis for some reason
and it's coming in his own mouth what's
saving that anime were eyes go all
sideways and her tongues out you guys
know what I'm talking about I don't
think that's from a an anime
specifically though isn't that just kind
of like a trope in you know what I'm
talking about I'm the only one here who
doesn't watch anime alright you guys are
all I know what you're referencing I
just didn't know it was from it's that
one zero that one girl that everybody
hates on who's like it's like their eyes
go cry okay let's move on
it's from hentai there's like the
izybelle crossfire and their tongue is
out there drooling
well anyway I imagine some this is a
sonic fanfic of that is what it would
look like and there's like hum all over
his face
for some reason because it's on tumblr
by the way I heard that pornhub was
thinking about buying tumblr back to
bring porn back to Tom's awesome that's
epic they'll just turn tumblr and so
like barn blur well it was before anyway
20 minutes ago an energy surge knock
down power across the entire Pacific I
came prepared I need someone who can
figure out it since the game
and where's bear that you just really
think you're suggesting
the Jim Carrey are you in charge here
yes I am I'm wrong
mommy charge allow me to clarify in a
sequentially ranked hierarchy based on
level of critical importance the
disparity between us is too vast to
qualified agents though
the doctor thinks you're basic listen
pal I don't know if you bro this is what
they chose of the movie this is the
highlight of a comical pinnacle of the
film let me translate so here's here's
where this has a huge problem people who
are fans of Sonic are my age got an
explanation for you by the way that's
what I just put Oh Dan okay so well I
guess we've probably moved on pasture
but comes from the genre of hentai
called ahi go where the girl is [ __ ]
so hard they make that kind of face or
guy I don't know I ain't gay the top
comment on explaining it okay so they
get so they enjoy the sex so much they
go cross that and roll there you go
by the way there's no it's no wonder you
guys are in cells when you're watching
that like how can you watch that and be
well adjusted to life imagining girls
going cross-eyed and drooling because
they're enjoying sex so much anyway the
people that are Sonic fans are my age
and yet this humour is catered towards
12 year olds so who exactly is this for
I'm sorry major what was your name
so so cringy dude I mean Jim Carrey uh I
mean everybody loves Jim Carrey but why
did you take this movie on yeah it's a
huge question mark money I would assume
money but he's so rich I mean people bet
I feel like he probably gets a lot of
movie offers yeah he'll I pick this is
where I could do anything you're right
yeah Jim Carrey could do anything he's
dramatic he's comical he's got it all
he's worth 150 million dollars he's on
top of the world dr. Robotnik you read
that script and you thought that was a
good dialogue maybe these friends with
the directors I'm sure you know
sometimes friends call in favors you
really don't want to do some Godfather
[ __ ] one day we'll ask a favor of you
that day may never come but today is
that day Jim Carrey I have a favor to
ask of you
I know that you will not want to do this
but if you're a call when you came up in
your career I happen to I took out the
guy I killed a man who was your
competition so that you would become a
star and now look how far you've gone
Jim Perry I ask you for this favor
my son is making a movie about Sonic the
Hedgehog and I asked you Jim
only you could be dr. Robotnik this role
was meant for you Jim and might I remind
you you do you owe me a favor
that you cannot refuse
and so with light in my heart Jim Carrey
with this favor that you so graciously
owe me I demand that you will play dr.
Robotnik in the Sonic in the Sonic movie
right deal I just looked it up it's the
the director it's his debut first movies
his debut I mean he's worked on other
movies but this is his uh world debut I
swear to god there's something like that
like there's no reason for Jim Carrey to
do this unless he's being extorted by
the god papa
he's getting called in a favor right now
now did you hear that the director said
they're gonna redo ya Sonic in this
movie yeah they're gonna redesign is
that is an unbelievable amount of work
like they've already made its you know
it's gonna be they're probably gonna do
it super ghetto where like they're gonna
try to like adjust it and then re render
the whole movie yep probably I mean yeah
I feel bad and then they're like well
you're already here to be honest with
you I do want to watch this film it's
gonna be such a trainer it might be so
bad it's good consolation doctor your
basic yeah actually that was his
assistant translating yeah what he did
say was what's your name nobody cares
got him that's epic dialogue got Ian did
somebody's got dirt on Jim Carrey
there's literally no excuse for him to
be in this film his directorial debut
come on I'm gonna watch this though
[Music]
meow
I hate you Sonic
why is his voice like that his voice
doesn't work you should shoot him no he
does shoot him by the way why if he's so
[ __ ] fast
why was he hit by a dart that was a
comment I can't take credit for that
observation but it's true he's so fast
he broke the speed sound of speed right
there on that road he's so epic his hair
is made of electricity but he just got
shot by poison dart by some Joe Schmoe
sorry Sonic whose voice is that
I recognize the voice whose voice is
that damn does Sani Oh it's Ben Schwartz
jean-ralphio
Oh epic no but thank you for asking
whatever this creature is our job is to
security neutralize it see what makes it
tick
and gotta be so bad bro movie yeah if
this is the trailer - epic bed and this
is like a high budget film I mean they
have big actors apparently I'm not sure
that they they probably should have put
more into the budget of those special
effects instead of Jim Carrey are you
kidding Jim Carrey they're like we have
100 million dollar budget they're like
okay 90 million to get Jim Carrey oh my
god can't wait
this song literally has no bent this
song has no bearing there's no
explanation for this song
dude he's literally look how fast he is
and he got shot by poison dart i've
watched
no problem I took 9 million steps today
bro you got shot by a poisoned dart how
can you do all these things
simultaneously like the continuity
mistake on that is so bad do you have
your child in that bank no I mean yes
it's a child but it's not mine so that's
a Joe here child
smells like bodies bringing an old ham
sandwich
oh wait didn't he used to say Axe body
spray I have a memory of them you can
have an end game dude that's the worst
trailer I've ever seen in my life tip
toes tip no well tip Wow yeah I don't
know so a song like this is so good and
then to not use it properly so awful
what's his sin yeah in fact whoever
license that to them should be ashamed
cuz when you're taking something that
half Coolio wants a paycheck god bless
him mm-hmm
here's my paper yeah yeah but when you
take a song like that and you put
footage with it it's like immediately
good usually right and they [ __ ] it up
it doesn't even make sense what they did
but you're right it's one of those songs
it's like like you put anything in slow
motion yes it's awesome yeah Sonic oh my
god yeah that's the worst that's gonna
be the worst movie ever made
I predict I'm gonna make a Rotten
Tomatoes prediction for this movie I
think it's gonna get like definitely
under I'm gonna make a bold prediction
cuz I think it's obviously gonna get
under 50 that's obvious but the question
is how risky do I want to put myself out
there i under 10 is a bold but possible
under 10 is very rare but I'm confident
to say under 20% do you ever I mean you
know I was gonna say like 20-something
should we make exact number guesses and
then we can compare I predict 12% maybe
eight I say 28 28 well that's optimistic
do you guys have a any horse in this
race this is rotten tomatoes right yes
Ron tomatoes the way they score it's
just what percent of my reviews so uh
I'm gonna go with zero I'm gonna be
really bold I don't think this is gonna
you think it's gonna get a straight zero
I mean that's a I don't only happen is
that happened
yeah damn can you cousin when all that
means is that there's nobody that gives
it the record even walk even in like
slightly positive review which can you
guys it's not really possible with a
list of 0% rotten tomatoes yeah probably
I think the new Will Ferrell movie the
Holmes and Watson can you send me a link
I'm gonna pull it up I'm fascinated by
this 0 / centers it's an exclusive list
ask an exclusive club yeah I mean well
barrel hasn't made a good movie in a
[ __ ] long hot minute here we go
Co % is definitely possibility but the
ridiculous six got a zero max steel got
a zero I don't remember that oh wait
they're like mixing in hundred percents
with zero presence as a stupid list the
ridiculous 6 max Steel's haven't heard
of these ridiculous six was I think a an
Adam Sandler straight to never saw that
0% man that's an achievement even for
our I gotta change my guess here cuz I
didn't know well here Bucky Larson born
restart isn't that another Adam Sandler
- Adam stan is like amazing
zero percent nobody recommended it baby
geniuses - that's a zero John's they're
evil
whoa Pinocchio's 0% I didn't know about
this this guy
Roberto been engi he had a coaster
critical acclaim when in 1997 his little
film life is beautiful won three Academy
Awards right and he was like this
incredible overnight success but isn't
next film a life action retelling of the
classic children's tale Pinocchio was
creepy and poorly made misguided vanity
project got a zero percent I'm
fascinated to watch that whoa that's
amazing I don't care about $100 the
revenge
Pudsey the dog the movie super babies
zero percent so they're out there gaudy
I mean that was just last year another
thing with John Travolta that's a zero
percent gaudy Mac and me I have no idea
what that is
Oh Mac you don't know what McNamee is no
but it looks awful oh it's amazing it's
like an ET ripoff that was made by
McDonald's in the 80s oh yes a
McDonald's like alright and there are
like multiple like extremely long
McDonald's product placements throughout
it oh my good old even for like
advertisers to think you know what we're
no sin except we're gonna make a movie
our own ads in it that's so epic Mac and
me only seen the scene of the the kid in
a wheelchair Oh flying off the clothing
off the cliff no that's from Mac and me
yeah that's Rebecca me did it's worth
the watch call it matter there are a lot
of really funny scenes and we need
McDonald's I want McDonald's and a coke
even at the thought of it precious cargo
again Bruce Willis has been in some
stinkers but this one is 0% a thousand
words
oh poor Eddie Murphy that guy's been on
out such a long losing streak like
[ __ ] 0% oh yeah it's such a shame cuz
he's such a funny guy his stand-up is so
amazing but 0% wagons East chump candy
yeah he was a see you made some bad ones
too look who's talking now John Travolta
has gotta have a he's on this looks
quite a few times yeah John Travolta's
got a hold some record for the most
worst movies ever
0% Mary Poppins that's 100
- super surfer dude Matthew McConaughey
0% Gotti that had 0% yeah I mean I
didn't see that one but whoa god-awful
do you know how bad a movie has to be
for every single critical I've to be
like I don't recommend you see this huh
poor John Travolta man I think he's only
made two good movies in his whole life
which is pulp fiction and grease I don't
even like grease but people like grease
sarin in a fever I yeah I shouldn't even
make I don't know what I'm talking about
I shouldn't make I just looked it up and
it looks like there's Ron tomatoes
there's only been 29 movies with zero
percent well what the hell am I looking
at this list for let me see that one all
right here its Wikipedia page oh they
got a witness what I'm talking to go
let's get down to the nitty-gritty here
here we go let's get we got charts
staying alive list of list of films with
zero percent rating around tomato let me
go by year here let's go staying alive
is actually the sequel of Saturday Night
Fever
so another Travolta movie oh oh you're
right holy [ __ ] zero percent he might he
might be the record holder Adam believer
zero percent movies ridicu times yeah
there's this is fantastic the Nutcracker
in 3d yes good man
yeah Pinocchio Eli actually I'm very
curious to watch this man yeah can we
watch a trailer I'm intrigued by this
Pinocchio the year was 2000 - let me
watch a trailer for this I really wanted
on a rabbit alright now there's a good
rabbit although I'm so curious about
this because this guy was like the
biggest deal in Hollywood yeah
after have you ever hoped
that fantasies could become real have
you ever wish have you ever held there's
one big adventure yeah this looks like a
part now your wish comes true you know
this is like like if Tommy Wiseau
just accidentally had a hit the first
time and then they get mad you two are
just neat he is coming to life
music
[Music]
I see dressed like that oh my don't
really know Pinocchio Holmes presents
two-time Academy Award winner Roberto
Benigni
oh my cuz they're like when we got the
two-time Academy Award winning we can
pretty much sell anything but the guy
had only made one film that guy that
trailer was whoa what's hard to watch
even the music was like weirdly
everything about it yes Wyatt why is
Pinocchio like a 50 year old man he's a
kid he's supposed to be his child
Geppetto's adopted a 50 year old man now
that's a weird twist on a classic tale
did you ever wish that fantasies could
become reality it's like bro if you
really care about the story cast a kid
why do you have to be the central
character freak is that genius no I
think the I have to track this one down
well anyway Sonic I'm gonna I'm guessing
a 12% you got to say a specific number
and then let's work all this yeah now
I'm gonna write it down then you're
doing zero I'm going with zero either I
guess because I already went so high
I'll just lower it to 20 but after
seeing this I my feel like it's gonna be
really low I don't think it's gonna be
zero though yeah Ian and Zach I'm saying
35 Wow it's optimistic I'll go 14 good
guess solid good yeah good guess 30
you're dreaming using choices right
rules here no no because I don't want I
don't want sniping you gotta get it
right all right whoever gets it exactly
right gets to direct
[Music]
gets to direct my next film where I star
as Woody from Toy Story and real at
live-action oh yeah
[Laughter]
Game of Thrones I wanted to talk about
mother effing Game of Thrones do we even
get into this is like a whole thing I'm
- I'm over it
- one we're gonna wrap this up - because
we're not live so we want to get it up
today we were saying we were already
have it up at one Oh God good we need to
do this live it's such a pain in the ass
because we're gonna be able to get it up
to like four and then it's like way too
late I wonder if we should post on
Monday morning I know but I'm talking
yeah I know there's a fan story that I
have to sneak in before we end this
podcast yeah let's do it mm-hmm this is
so [ __ ] epic I've been talking about
bad food like I'm obsessed with that so
this person sent me something that truly
I love I'm a fan of your channel and
when I saw the video I thought about
Ethan's love for weird Instagram foods
it's not from Instagram I don't really
know what it is but it's so weird to
disturb me I decided to share with you I
don't know the source of context my mom
showed it to me it says new kind of
pizza and Russian thank you
Alina Ellen on zero thank you God bus so
this is fantastic this is exactly what I
love either this I just want your real
reaction to this okay
the sound is so good - so he's scooping
french fries into a pizza box now he's
putting mozzarella cheese over the
french fries
so now he's piling on roast beef so kind
of meat out of a warmer I really like
roast beef right
he really piles it on man like keep
scooping like I'm like dude that's you
know that's a lot of me so now he's
putting on like roasted chicken on top
of the roast beef all in my pizza box my
deal on a bed of french fries back o on
over the French fries to complete what
he started the fries are going supposed
to do in that they going back on the
roast beef and grilled chicken back on
over the mozzarella for another layer of
cheese yep
every corner matters
now we are headed over to the sauce
section to put on mayonnaise we are
putting on ketchup
we are putting on
[Music]
onion
we were putting on lettuce now on a hot
bed of french fries and meat and of
course a couple tomatoes and I love how
he just pathetically draws the cucumber
on there what there you have it
delicious
that's called a Russian pie a Moscow pie
I think they know that all right are you
supposed to do it that's the dumbest
thing I can ever imagine putting on a
pizza box
well I guess they also make pizza but
they just have like this an ethnic
original dish it's probably the guy
posted to his Facebook pages like hey
guys here's how I kill myself
mmm would you guys try that I mean I
would take a bite but I can never see
myself ever wanting to eat that mm-hmm
Zach who likes art Zach you like Arby's
so I can tell that you want to try that
I'm a sick [ __ ]
you thought that looked good deal no I'm
not judging no I did that yeah the part
that throws me is like the vegetables
like why would you want lettuce on top
of a hot yeah the veggies kind of turned
my mouth throws me as the pizza box
yeah the pizza box is awesome do you
want to eat that from a pizza box like I
think it's just epic because they make
pizza and that the Moscow pie Moscow cow
pie yeah it's like who you kidding with
the veggies you know what I mean you
don't mind them do mayonnaise no or the
ketchup no if they put mustard on there
then that's a no-no mustard is what
that's the deal-breaker for ya I don't
like tomatoes either so I just feel like
okay well there you have it what what
what did what don't you like Zach cream
cheese
but I do like LOX bread which is weird
you like LOX and cream cheese but not
cream no no lock spread you know like
the mix the lox and cream cheese mix
it's a different labels cream cheese Oh
interesting what happened to you and
cream cheese when you're I don't love
bagels so what do you eat on your bagels
and lox
you know spread no no smear absolutely I
kind of imagine eating a bagel without a
schmear so dry cream cheese a cottage
cheese yeah so you like mozzarella
cheese I do any other weird food issues
with you that's pretty much it yeah
what's your favorite food really good
burger burger [ __ ] you or maybe some
pizza french fry lately what are you the
videos I Moscow the Moscow help I know
favorite good you know I would share
that with you Zack I appreciate if you
bring in something like that we can film
it let's make it we can have in the
intern just there what yeah I don't know
it's not really his job to go to make
sure like that I guess we're slowing
down here we have slowed down we have
grinded to a halt well we've done it all
we've seen it all we've said it all so
there's you can play the music now Dan
cuz there's only one way to say goodbye
on this god bless of God's day Friday
thank God it's Friday
let the food guide the czn guy that I
love on Instagram someone [ __ ] that's
the lamb god I call him so that's an
epic happy Friday to everybody thank you
for watching thank you for coming along
for the ride thing for the laughs the
gaffes the goofs and the right thank you
for giving me purpose thank you for
giving me substance thank you for giving
me a job and allowing me to work and
make a living doing these things that I
love thank you to the cast and the crew
Danny and Zach shredder shredder thank
you guys for your for your work and your
dedication and your your your everything
you do to make this show great thank you
to all the fans and everybody thank you
to ela who is my beautiful life my wife
my life my everything who has a
beautiful I he's I can already tell he's
cute we saw the ultrasound of his face
he but she's so close I mean June 6
that's less than a month away so we're
in baby can happen anytime
yeah pretty much so thank you to both
you and Theodore thank you - shredder
who has been such an angel throughout
all this and is so patient and loving we
love shredder like our own son he is our
firstborn and thank you once again to
everybody thank you to my mom for giving
birth to me
thank you to my mom's grandma for giving
birth to her thank you to Adam and Eve
who were there all swings um I'm gonna
kill myself
this is my goodbye speech thank you to
Adam and Eve for for being cast at the
Garden of Eden and giving birth to all
of civilization because they're human
cross you got the best of them thank you
to God - who allowed Adam to make pick
his own rib out and create Eve from
Mazon ribs that's why you're able to be
here so you should be thinking Adam for
doing that with his rib you know thank
you
thank you to God for whom none of this
would have been possible there'd be no
universe there'd be no space there be no
stars or earth or anything for us to
even be here to say thanks so as always
we have to end what thank you to God
thank you to Adam who took the rib out
thank you to my mom - gave birth to me
thank you guys for thank you look for
giving me the think of the gases they
can prove and take it everybody is
watching thank you and God bless
happy weekend
[Music]